- [Instructor] Now going
to talk about a people
that began to settle
and eventually conquer
much of Anatolia, modern-day Turkey
at the beginning of the
second millennium BCE,
and these people are
known as the Hittites,
and the word Hittite is referred to
in the Hebrew Bible, in the Old Testament,
and it's worth dissecting
that word a little bit
because the word comes from the idea
that this region that they conquer
in modern-day Turkey was
referred to as Hatti,
and Hatti had original inhabitants
known as the Hattians,
but the Hittites conquer
and displace these Hattians,
but they are referred to as the Hittites
because they settle in Hatti.
Now they're considered to
be Indo-European people.
This is a word that you will hear often
in World History, and that's because
what linguists have found is
that many modern languages
seem to have a root in what's called
proto-Indo-European language,
and I'll do a whole video on it,
but looking at linguistic structures,
we believe or one model is is that
many of the people who speak
these Indo-European languages
or these ones that are derived
from the proto-Indo-European,
and that includes
languages related to Greek.
We're talking about Latin,
we're talking about
the Germanic languages,
including what I'm speaking right now
which is English, which is fundamentally
a Germanic language with
a lot of Latin influence,
we're talking about Celtic,
but we're also talking
about more eastern languages like Persian,
and Hindi, and Bengali.
All of these have a lot
of commonalities to them
which we believe gives
evidence that, at one point,
it was a very closely
related group of people
who are coming from this Caucasus region,
and this map that you see here,
this shows one model for
how those people spread
and eventually broke
off into various tribes
speaking different, but
very related, languages.
So the fourth millennium BCE,
they were in this region right over here
which would be southern Russia,
the Caucasus right around there,
and then by 2500 BCE,
that's this orange area,
they had spread even further.
And then by 1000 BCE, they
had spread even further
and the Hittites would have
been one of those people
because they settle in
Anatolia right over here.
Now we don't know as
much about the Hittites
as we know about, say,
the ancient Egyptians
or the Mesopotamians, but we know that
they were a significant civilization.
Now if you look at this timeline here,
it shows the various civilizations
that were emerging around this time.
We're now talking about the mid
to late second millennium,
so this is 1700 BCE,
let me write that down just to make sure,
we know that's BCE, 1600
BCE, so on and so forth,
and I show these various civilizations
that existed around that time,
and they correspond to this map here.
So you have Mycenaean Greece
which emerges around 1600 BCE
all the way to about 1100 BCE.
You have the New kingdom of Egypt,
which is from about 1550 BCE
to a little bit after 1100 BCE,
and we do a whole series of videos
on ancient Egypt, and then we talk about
the Old Kingdom, the Middle Kingdom,
and of course, the New Kingdom.
And the New Kingdom of Egypt is important
because they're going to
be one of the key rivals
for the Hittites in this period.
The New Kingdom of Egypt
is often referred to
as the Egyptian Empire because it was
the most powerful time of ancient Egypt,
and you see that right over
here in this brown color.
Now in this purplish-blue color,
that is the Hittite civilization,
and this map right over here,
you can see that they started to
really settle and conquer that area
at the beginning of the second millennium,
and by 1600, you have
the Old Hittite kingdom,
and then as we get to about 1400 BCE,
you have the New Hittite Kingdom,
often known as the Hittite Empire,
and this is where they really
start to flex their muscle.
And notice, they're flexing their muscles
at roughly the same time as the Egyptians,
and so this map right over here,
this is in roughly the 14th century,
what this area looked like.
So we're talking roughly this zone,
and you can see there are
several civilizations,
many of them that were in their peak.
You see the Mitanni
Kingdom right over here.
You see the Middle Assyrian Empire.
We talk about them when
we talk about Mesopotamia,
and you see Kassite
Babylonia right over here.
The Kassites took over after the Amorites
under Hammurabi and his dynasty,
and we'll see that they
also have a connection
to the Hittites.
So this will hopefully
acquaint you with time.
These are Bronze Age civilizations.
The state of the art
technology for most of them
was bronze, which is
combining copper and tin,
and you can make weapons, and tools,
and jewelry with it.
Now what's interesting about the Hittites
is that they were one of the first
to start to use iron.
Iron required a little
bit more technology.
In order to smelt iron,
you have to get the furnace
to be even hotter, and
the Hittites, we know,
did make use of iron.
Now they are also known
as great charioteers.
This is an image of what a
Hittite chariot would look like,
and so with a combination
of iron chariots,
that's one of the things that helped them
establish something of an empire.
Now I mentioned that
they come into conflict
with many other peoples.
In fact, they come into
conflict with most of
the folks that you see on
this picture over here.
The first time that you really see them
in a significant way conquering things
is in 1595 BCE, and this would be
the Old Hittite Kingdom, but this is
what famously ends Hammurabi's dynasty,
the Amorite dynasty in
Babylon right over here.
They go to Babylon in 1595 BCE
and they overthrow it.
They're not able to maintain rule,
they have to go back.
There start to be fragmentation
dissension at home,
but it's the end of the
Amorites, and then eventually,
another group, the Kassites,
take over this region,
and you can see them in
gray right over here.
Now what's also interesting
in this timeline
that we have, and we're talking about
hundreds of years, it's important to keep
things in perspective, is that you see
that a lot of these
civilizations in the Middle East
and Mesopotamia, this
area's often referred to
as the Levant.
It's related to the word levante
from Italian for "to rise,"
because for the Romans, for the Europeans,
for those in the West, this
was where the sun rose,
this was the East, it was
the Eastern Mediterranean.
And so you have all of these civilizations
that are in the Levant
in the 14th century BCE,
in the 13th century BCE, but
then they start to decline,
and that general period after or around
the 12th century BCE is known
as the Bronze Age Collapse
when a lot of these civilizations become
a lot more fragmented.
Now I've already alluded to the fact,
and I talk about this in a lot of detail
in the Ancient Egypt video,
that the chief rivals
of the Hittites were the Egyptians,
and vice versa, and it's
particularly the case
in the 14th and 13th
centuries where both of them
were quite powerful empires.
You have the Egyptians
moving up into this area
right over here, modern-day
Israel and Lebanon,
and you have the Hittites moving down
from the north, from Anatolia
into modern-day Syria.
And there's a whole series of conflicts
that emerge in this area,
and one of the most famous
and one of the most significant
happens in 1274 BCE,
and that is the Battle of Kadesh.
Kadesh is an area that has switched hands
multiple times between the
Egyptians and the Hittites.
At this time, you have Ramses II,
considered the greatest Egyptian Pharaoh,
he is the Pharaoh, he
is the ruler of Egypt,
and he wants to recapture Kadesh.
And what's significant
about the Battle of Kadesh,
it's the earliest battle where we have
a significant account of the tactics,
of the strategy, of the
formation of the troops.
We know that there were over
50,000 soldiers involved.
It's currently believed it might be
the largest chariot battle
in all of world history
that we at least know about,
and the actual outcome
of the Battle of Kadesh
seems to be a stalemate.
Our accounts of it come
primarily from the Egyptians.
We don't have any significant Hittite
surviving accounts of
the Battle of Kadesh,
but it gave us a lot of information.
But beyond just the battle
itself being significant,
because we have this detail about
what battles were like at that time period
with chariots and the type
of tactics that were used,
what's also significant is 16 years after
the Battle of Kadesh,
you have the Egyptian-Hittite
Peace Treaty in 1258 BCE.
And the reason why this is significant
is this is sometimes referred to as
the first peace treaty in history.
I would qualify a little bit as saying
it's the first peace
treaty that we know about
in this part of the world,
and this right over here
is the Hittite version of it,
and what's especially cool
about this peace treaty,
and just so you know what
these other pictures are,
this is a Hittite ramp discovered at
the Hittite capital of Hattusa.
This is some pictures of the Hittite
gods of the underworld.
But once again, we don't have as complete
of a picture of the Hittite versus, say,
the Egyptians, but what's also neat
about this treaty, it's sometimes called
the Treaty of Kadesh, but it doesn't refer
directly to Kadesh.
These folks have been in
conflict with each other
for nearly over 100 years right over here,
so this treaty is really to talk about
not just Kadesh, and this treaty happened
16 years after the Battle of Kadesh,
but to talk about, "Let's
just have a permanent peace
"between our two great empires,"
and what's cool about it is
we have surviving accounts
from the Hittites that
were discovered in Hattusa,
and we also have a symmetric account
that we get from the Egyptians,
and so this is the one from the Hittites
and this is from the Egyptians.
It's written in Acadian,
which wasn't their language.
Acadian, we talked about,
was a Semitic language,
and they used cuneiform
script, which remember,
we get from the Sumerians,
but it's cool to get
the same treaty written
in different scripts
from both sides of the conflict.
And I'll just read a little bit of it
because it's neat to just think about it,
and of course they didn't
write it in this language,
modern English wouldn't show up for many,
actually thousands of
years from this point,
but this is a translation.
"Now from the beginning
of the limits of eternity,
"as for the situation of
the Great ruler of Egypt
"with the Great Prince
of Hatti, the god did not
"permit hostility to occur between them,
"through a regulation.
"But in the time of Muwatallis,
the Great Prince of Hatti,
"my brother," so this is
from the point of view
of Hattusilis, who is the Hittite king
at the time of the treaty, "he fought with
"Ramses Meri-Amon," the Pharaoh Ramses,
"the great ruler of Egypt.
"But hereafter, from this
day, behold Hattusilis,
"the Great Prince of Hatti,
is under a regulation
"in order not to permit hostility to occur
"between them forever."
Those are big words.
"Behold, Hattusilis," sometimes
it's spelled Hattusili,
"the Great Prince of
Hatti, has set himself
"in a regulation with
User-maat-Re Setep-en-Re,"
that's sometimes how
Ramses is referred to,
"the Great ruler of Egypt,
beginning from this day,
"to cause that good peace and brotherhood
"occur between us forever, while he is
"in brotherhood with me
and he is at peace with me,
"and I am in brotherhood with him
"and I am in peace with him forever.
"Behold, I, as the Great Prince of Hatti,
"am with Ramses Meri-Amon, in good peace
"and in good brotherhood.
"The children of the
children of the Great Prince
"of Hatti are in brotherhood and peace
"with the children of the
children of Ramses Meri-Amon,
"the Great ruler of Egypt, for they are
"in our situation of brotherhood
"and our situation of peace.
"The land of Egypt,
with the land of Hatti,
"shall be at peace and in brotherhood
"like unto us forever.
"Hostilities shall not
occur between them forever."
So not only are they, and
this is just part of the text,
it's actually quite interesting,
do a web search for the
Egyptian-Hittite Treaty text,
and you can actually get the whole text,
this is just part of an excerpt of it,
but they go into much more details
about how they might
provide aid for each other,
how they're not going to have conflict,
et cetera, et cetera.
So I'll leave you there,
but the important thing
to take away is some
of these modern notions
of peace treaties and military tactics,
they go deep into history, and this is
some of the earliest evidence we find,
but I would suspect as
we discover more things,
we might find even earlier evidence.